Britain and
Greece are kind
of fighting with each other
over these statues.
These are sculptures
that are 2000 years old
and they're housed in the British Museum
in London
Back in the 1800s,
a British lord took
these sculptures from Greece,
brought them to the UK.
Crucially, he did get permission
from the Ottoman Empire,
which at the time did control Greece.
But once Greece got their independence,
they asked for the statues back.
And of course, Britain said “no.”
Fast forward to last week
when the Greek prime
minister said this on the BBC,
We feel that these sculptures
belong to Greece
and that they were essentially stolen.
And this pissed off
the British prime minister
so much
that he canceled his meeting
with the Greek prime minister.
But like, come on.
These statues are from Greece.
There's literally
a place in the Parthenon
that is dedicated to these statues
that's just sitting there blank,
waiting for them
to return to their rightful place
But the British are just not
going to budge on this.
They're like, “No, we stole these,
and we're going to just keep them,
like we did
with everything else
that we've stolen from around the world.”
If you want to better global politics,
follow along for more.